- So, former officer Derek Chauvin
has been remanded into custody.
He is now in jail.
Eventually, he will appeal his case.
This was always a case
where if Chauvin was
convicted of anything,
it was clear that he was going to appeal.
Generally speaking, criminal appeals
have a very, very low rate
of actually changing the outcome at trial.
It can happen, but it's pretty rare.
But one thing that will
definitely not happen
is this case will not go before
the United States Supreme Court.
People will talk about taking things
all the way to the Supreme
court all the time,
but the Supreme Court
doesn't really intervene,
number one, in state cases that much.
And number two, they
don't really intervene
when it's just an application
of facts to the law.
All of the legal standards
that were at issue
in the Chauvin trial are
pretty well cut and dry,
so there's nothing for the US
Supreme Court to intervene on.
It's possible that the
Minnesota Supreme Court
might weigh in on the murder 3
charge that was brought here,
but that's not likely to
have much of an effect
because Chauvin was convicted of murder 2.
So, while you might be
seeing this in court,
you will not be seeing this
in the US Supreme Court.